Rosen you know bring it into your
industry so you know in the political
world world you're like well uh uh I
don't know who's behind it the people
that are behind it you know some people
will say well every war was financed by
Bankers all the way back to rotchild to
UK to this to Colonial everything's been
financed by Bankers so it's a Bankers
War right yeah industri
military-industrial complex no it's the
bigger guys the coch brothers they
chooseing no it's the Soros no it's this
in Hollywood you know you the the people
that look at it from the outside they
say wow you know these guys must have
been you know great on how to make it up
and I remember I was working with this
one guy at Bal and super good-looking
guy 65 blue eyes white guy all this
stuff and I'm spending time with him and
all of a sudden one day we go partying
with this guy I realized how he made his
money which was crazy but he used to be
in Hollywood and he says one day he gets
invited to a party with uh David gin's
house and he's doing work he's doing
movies he said we're about to make
it so so him and his best friend go over
there they're both good-looking guys in
their 20s and I say David wants you
upstairs in his room so they go to his
room and David's like this is the story
he's telling me now whether there's
truth to this or not this guy didn't
seem like he needs to a story
like this but he says so David says hey
you guys I got a movie I want to put you
guys in great yeah but I need you to
please him right in front of me and this
guy's like what yeah I need and his
friends like dude I'm down if you're
down dude I want to get a job in a movie
it's like hell no I'm out so he left he
left the industry I'm done with it for
us from the outside watching in and you
hear stories like uh Weinstein or you
hear stories of gfin you hear stories
about these guys how how dark was it
back in the days in Hollywood and how
much of this was happening how'd you get
past it for a person that wanted to come
up and compete you know cuz in politics
you have to do favors to find a way to
go up right the favors could be
different kind of favors that you do how
dirty was it and how much of that has
changed today within Hollywood well I
never for some reason well I always say
it's because nobody ever wanted to
me that's not true Rosanne that's not
true I will take you down right now
that's Rosanne test me well you
don't I have no power in Hollywood so
that's what you think steep into my
office we're g to get you your own show
baby girl I'm talking about you know
them so I didn't have to you know I know
don't put it past me rosan I'm just
letting you know right now legendary
story that
old that left a million years ago
but uh
uh I
didn't that didn't have nothing to do
with me I didn't have to I used to have
a good joke about it that I say you know
what do who do well it's not it won't
work here but uh no I didn't have to do
that I say uh I was uh one of the few
you that made it on
talent but uh no I uh I love her uh but
no I didn't get none of that happened to
me but I knew people that it did happen
to and because I was working uh to uh
help
kids uh kids who were you know in
slavery and from drugs and sex and stuff
in Hollywood they had run away to be
Stars and you know that's what happened
to them they' get mixed up like that and
be used uh I heard their stories and I
knew it was common and I knew that uh
it's just a dent of iniquity and uh I
heard from other people that you know
everybody knew somebody who had to do
that kind of deal but especially it
seemed to be in the movies and the uh
music but
TV I didn't I don't know it probably
went on but I I didn't I had to bully my
way on the TV though but they didn't
want me at all what do you mean by bully
well they didn't want to do a show with
me in it did they try to recast you like
Rosanna they who's they the network oh
okay got it they didn't they yeah they
were like I remember the day I was
shooting my pilot my sister was there
and there was she said she was standing
next to all my agents and the producers
of the show and they didn't know if she
was my sister of course I always have a
plant see good good and uh uh she says
she she says that they go who's going to
watch this show about two fat people two
fat and all low this and that she told
me wow yeah how they R yeah but then you
know my not Cosby off yeah and you know
I but I knew I knew American people
wanted to see themselves not degraded
mhm and they wanted to see theirselves
portrayed as kind of heroic cuz I did
when I was watch TV coming up but uh you
know I had to force it and they uh then
they had to eat my dust good and they
didn't like doing that neither and they
they never liked it but I'd be like you
know I I relished it I may not have to
say it was a high school dropout telling
them people from Harvard oh it was a joy
it really was a joy who who was somebody
you met that was kind of like you know
when you're making it you're then you're
like number one and you're making a
million and a million a week who was who
was the celebrity you met for the first
time like that's kind of cool like I'm
having dinner with XYZ I'm you know I'm
having met met all my Idols I mean that
was the most amazing thing uh well I
mean I could name them off it I forget
everybody's name but uh number uh I
can't even say number one but as a comic
to meet all my comic idols and hang out
with them and have a few drinks and
smoke a joint and you know Jam jokes
with I I got to meet Richard PRI I got
to meet and hang with Dick Gregory who
was a God you know God and he ran for
president on the same ticket I ran on
and that's why I ran because of Dick
Gregory but uh uh you know Phyllis
Diller was a friend Joan Rivers Rodney
Dangerfield he left me his pot in his
well oh W get out I got his pipe and his
marijuana and for my did you smoke it
did you keep it no I didn't dare smoke
it I got it in my office that's great
yeah and uh you know God I'm forgetting
everybody what about George Carlin yeah
I loved him too met him rosan did was um
he's a geni oh yeah he was everything he
said I was just going to say it right
now it seems like this is sort of like
what your go yeah we're we're War like
people he like if you're Brown you like
the bomb brown people he's like if
you're Brown you better watch the FL he
was the best oh he was funny till the
end so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right
here